we're told that marvin has an inflatable
wading pool in his backyard the pool is
cylindrical with a base area of four
square meters and a height of 60
centimeters
what is the volume of the pool in cubic
meters
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right now let's work through this
together and let's just first visualize
what
this cylindrical wading pool would look
like
it would look something like this a
wading pool is kind of a small pool
where you can just hang out a bit in it
you're not necessarily going to swim
around too much in it
so
it might look something
like this i know i'm not drawing it
perfectly it's kind of a hand-drawn
situation and i'm making it transparent
so that we can see the base
so the wading pool would look something
like that they tell us that we have a
base area of four square meters so this
area
right over here that's the base
that is four square meters and it has a
height of 60 centimeters tell us that
right over there so this height
is 60 centimeters
so the volume our reaction might be to
say okay the volume of a cylinder is the
area of the base times the height and so
in this case why wouldn't we just take 4
times 60
times 60 and we would get a volume of
240 and we want it in cubic meters so we
just say 240 cubic meters is this true
did i just do this correctly
well some of you might have realized
that what i just multiplied i didn't
multiply four square meters times 60
meters to get 240 cubic meters i just
multiplied four square meters times 60
60 centimeters and if you multiply these
two things your actual units would not
be cubic meters it would end up with
units of metered squares centimeters
which is not what they want and that is
kind of a bizarre set of units so in
order to get the answer in cubic meters
we would want to re-express 60
centimeters in terms of meters
well how many meters is 60 centimeters
well a hundred centimeters make a meter
so i could write it this way
so
100
centimeters
equal one
meter
or another way you could think about it
is one centimeter is equal to
100
of
a meter
and so 60 centimeters is going to be
equal to 60
hundredths
of
a meter
so now we can apply this because we're
dealing with you with meters
consistently now so we can say so this
is actually wrong we could say the
volume is going to be equal to the base
in square meters i'm going to write the
units down to make sure we're doing the
right thing
times the height times
60
over 100
meters and now everything works out
4 times 60 over 100 is going to be
240
over
100 and then meter squared times meter
we are left with cubic meters which is
exactly what they asked us for and of
course we could rewrite this
as
2.4
cubic meters
and we are done